Цей гігантський черв'як риє нову лінію метро.
А це - ефект зоряного неба під Берліном.
З якими технологіями будують підземку в Німеччині?
І навіщо потрібно було заморожувати ґрунт під Берліном?
Метро у Німеччині, так би мовити "в чистому вигляді", є лише у чотирьох містах: Берліні, Гамбурзі, Мюнхені та Нюрнберзі.
Загалом же по країні здебільшого прижився комбінований варіант.
У 20 німецьких містах підземні станції є частиною маршрутів міських електричок і трамваїв.
Метро у Німеччині з'явилося у 1902 році. Перші станції побудували в Берліні.
У проєктуванні активну участь брав німецький інженер і винахідник Вернер фон Сіменс.
Через 10 років перша лінія метро відкрилася у Гамбурзі.
І тільки потім, аж майже через 60 років, історію німецького метрополітену продовжив Мюнхен.
Лише у 1971 році там звели перші станції і прискорили будівництво перед Олімпійськими іграми, що відбулися наступного року.
У 70-ті відкрився метрополітен і в сусідньому баварському місті Нюрнберг.
Німецький метрополітен U-Bahn і міська електричка S-Bahn традиційно конкурують за джерела фінансування.
Після возз'єднання Німеччини, коли Берлін знову став єдиним містом, почався будівельний бум для уніфікації інфраструктури.
Нинішня ж мережа метро і міських електричок здебільшого задовольняє транспортні потреби столиці.
Берлінське метро має 9 ліній загальною довжиною понад 150 кілометрів.
Для порівняння: довжина трьох ліній у Києві - 70 кілометрів.
Найдовша берлінська лінія U7 - 32 кілометри. Вона ж є і найдовшою повністю підземної лінією в Німеччині.
У київському метрополітені - 52 станції. Натомість у берлінському - 175 станцій.
Та більшість з них - неглибокого залягання і без довгих ескалаторів.
Але остання відкрита станція - "Музейний острів" - стала однією з найглибших у Берліні.
Вона розташована на глибині 20 метрів. Її відкрили у липні цього року після майже десятирічного будівництва.
"Червона ратуша", "Музейний острів" та "Під липами" - це три нові станції лінії U5, яка з'єднує площу Александрплатц із Бранденбурзькими воротами.
Тож тепер від берлінської телевежі – найвищої споруди Німеччини - до будівлі Бундестагу можна дістатися за 10 хвилин.
Ось як будували підземний тунель довжиною 2 кілометри 200 метрів.
Під замовлення виготовили тунельну машину під назвою "Берлінде".
Це такий собі 135-метровий сталевий "черв'як", в середині якого - справжня підземна фабрика.
Ця футуристична конструкція рила землю й одночасно обкладала стіни тунелю ось такими залізобетонними елементами.
Швидкість - 20 метрів за добу.
Так під річкою Шпреє і далі вздовж столичного бульвару "Під липами" і аж до станції метро "Бранденбурзькі ворота"
було прорито дві окремі тунельні труби - спершу північну, потім південну.
Після цього, щоб побудувати підземну станцію метро, 28 тисяч кубічних метрів ґрунту вирішили заморозити.
Для цього протягнули 95 сталевих труб, кожна завдовжки 105 метрів, обладнаних системою заморозки.
Болотисту землю під річкою фактично перетворили на скелю.
Навіщо? Бо лід не пропускає воду і поводить себе стабільно. А далі справа вже за спецтехнікою.
Заморожений піщаний ґрунт розтрощили, наче гірську породу.
Потім все забетонували і поступово розморозили ґрунт, ліквідуючи протікання.
В підсумку станція стала герметичною. Тоді взялися за оздоблювані роботи.
На станції "Музейний острів" встановили понад шість з половиною тисяч світлових точок у стелі - ефект зоряного неба під Берліном.
Загалом на нову ділянку лінії метро U5 витратили понад 525 мільйонів євро.
Це був теж один з німецьких "довгобудів", через технологічну складність прокладання тунелів під річкою
та під фундаментами історичних будівель в самісінькому центрі Берліна.
Крім того, зважали на можливі бомби часів Другої світової та археологічні розкопки.
Центральним берлінським бульваром, що називається "Під липами" і під яким велися ці роботи з будівництва метро,
щодня проїжджають в середньому 15 тисяч автомобілів.
Міська влада сподівається, що нова ділянка лінії U5 перебере на себе 20 відсотків дорожнього руху і тим самим покращить екологію в місті.